have you forgotten what happened to our
grandfather the Mad King invited him to
King's Landing and roasted him alive hey
everybody it's Charlie so a really cool
thing happened this past week George R
Martin released a new excerpt from the
book that's being released this November
the sort of foreshadows what's happening
when Daenerys goes to the north with Jon
Snow at the beginning of season eight so
we got to break it down it's also some
really cool history we'll all be able to
read about it in November because the
book will actually be pretty big I will
do giveaways for that when we get a
little bit closer but until then I'm
still doing that season 1 4k blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video so Daenerys and Jon are
sailing to white Harbor on the sex boat
then they're gonna make their way to
Winterfell obviously it's gonna take a
while fast travel within the Game of
Thrones TV universe condenses a lot of
that the book excerpt provides a much
more detailed explanation of what
actually happens when she's travelling
around the north but it also gives you a
POV perspective for her character so
it's sort of like getting a Daenerys POV
as she's travelling around the north
meeting all these people meeting the
Starks from the time now this is
happening 58 years after Aegon's
conquest so it's almost 250 years before
what's happening on the TV show during
season 8 so a long long time ago but
there's some funny references to what
happens when she tries to fly her dragon
north of the wall in what the Starks of
the time are like very different from
the Starks of today so you'll notice a
very familiar personality types quick
recap though Queen Alice and the reason
why she shares a lot in common with
Daenerys is is because she's sort of
raining during a time after a really bad
period in a really bad King so what
happened is his Aegon the conquerer had
two sons who were both kings the first
one king inez the first was a weak King
he had a bunch of children amongst them
Jo Harris the first who would eventually
become king and marry his younger sister
Allison so again remember Targaryens
wedding brother to sister but they're
the grandchildren of Aegon the conquerer
he married both of his sisters so sister
YV is still very popular at that time
and is the first was a weak King his
brother was Meg or who would eventually
become maegor the cruel the person who
built the dragon pit after blowing up
the old great set of King's Landing
I think when we were getting Season
seven episodes I did a video on the
origin of the dragon pit it's really
interesting maegor the cruel dies with
no heirs remember we're talking about
Cersei being like maegor the cruel so
it's implied that she's going to die
with no heirs what happens is is because
Anna's the first his brother even though
he died had many children the line of
succession passes back to his side of
the family
Joe Harris ascends the throne his wife
Alison becomes queen she has a dragon
named silver wing none of the kings of
Westeros since Aegon the conquerer have
visited the north so they figured that
it's time that they go and check and
make sure everyone's doing okay in sort
of glad-hand with the Starks who are
still wardens of the north obviously at
the last minute her husband King Joe
Harris is called to mediate this dispute
so she ends up going by herself so she
takes a boat to white Harbor along with
her dragons in her retinue so she gets
this big reception from the manderlys at
white Harbor they threw this big feast
everybody loves her it's great that she
gets really worried when it comes time
to take her dragon and go to Winterfell
because the Lord of Winterfell at the
time was Lord Alaric Stark and he sounds
based on the way the George R Martin
describes him is being exactly like
Tywin Lannister so it's funny to see
this personality type show up especially
amongst the stark so you traditionally
think of as very good people but I'll
just read this part of the excerpt
because it's actually pretty funny so it
says after taking her leave of white
Harbor the Queen's written you sailed up
the white knife to its rapids that
proceeded overland to Winterfell whilst
Alison herself flew ahead on silver wing
the warmth of her reception at white
Harbor was not duplicated at the ancient
seat of the kings in the north where
Alaric stark and his sons alone emerged
to greet her when her dragon landed
before the castle gates Lord Alaric had
a flinty reputation a hard man people
said Stern and unforgiving tight-fisted
almost to the point of being humorless
joyless and cold
even Lord Manderley who was his
bannermen had not disagreed Stark was
well respected in the north he said but
not loved Lord manderlys fool had put it
else wise methinks Lord Alaric had not
moved his bowels since he was 12 so
they're basically just saying that the
Lord of Winterfell at the time the stark
was a total [ __ ]
very much in the vein of Tywin Lannister
but then when she lands her dragons
Silverwing right in front of Winterfell
and they walk out to greet her is this
really funny reception he won't allow
her to bring the dragon within the walls
of Winterfell
he says I've not seen Harrenhal but I
know what happened there he makes a
slight about the King not coming with
her and then says they best hurry up if
they're gonna get here because we can't
feed a thousand men and winter is coming
remember you can't really have a scene
with starts where someone doesn't
reference winter is coming
but what happens is is that while she's
staying there at Winterfell eventually
her stubborn charm sort of wins over
Lord Alaric she visits the god wood
she travels all over the castles she
meets Lord Alaric's children he has two
sons and one daughter eventually she
wins them all over even Lord Alaric goes
to meet her dragon wearily but you
imagine that because he doesn't have any
Targaryen blood in him it's not like
when Jon Snow was meeting drogon or
anything like that she takes her leave
flies on silver wings back up to Castle
black to meet the brothers of the Nights
Watch and eventually because no one
really has a lot of information about
what's going on north of the wall at the
time she tries to fly the dragon over
the wall and it refuses her three times
every time she says that she tries to
veer towards the wall it veers away she
lands it in the Brothers of the Nights
Watch are really confused like what are
you what are you doing why is your
dragon acting all weird she has to make
a joke so that they won't think that
anything's wrong but she's deeply deeply
troubled so it's a way of sort of
foreshadowing what's happening later
with the White Walkers during present
day the dragon itself fire made flesh
this magical creature can sense
something really terrible is north of
the wall so it's a weird way of getting
inside their heads like you never get a
dragon POV chapter you just sort of get
a sense for what they're thinking based
on how tenaris is interacting with them
on screen alison is writing to her
husband King Joe Harris talking about
how she's really worried about what's
going on up there she says never before
has Silver Wing refused to take me where
I wish to go I laughed about it when I
came down again so the black brothers
would not realize anything was amiss but
it troubled me then and it troubles me
still so this book is actually coming
out in November you'll be able to buy it
is basically the history of the
Targaryen family starting with Aegon the
conquerors children so you get maegor
the cruel
you get your Harrison Queen Alice Anne
but it's supposed to be a two-part book
and I assume that part two will take us
relatively close to present day
but Martin already said that part two
isn't gonna be released till way way
down the future because all the material
that he's collected in this book is
stuff that he created while he was
writing the main novels so it's like a
bunch of deleted scenes that he's
collected and turned into another book
so sort of gives you a preview for what
it's going to be like for John and
Daenerys particularly Daenerys when they
land in the north because she's never
been there in the North remembers
particularly that the Mad King Daenerys
his father killed the former Lord of
Winterfell back at the beginning of
Robert's rebellion or one of the
premiere events that led to Robert's
rebellion so you have to imagine that
Daenerys is gonna have to spend some
time winning over the Starks
particularly Sansa in Arya although Arya
will probably be quicker to accept her
just because John is so readily
accepting of her and she takes her cues
from John so if John vouchers for
someone arya would probably take them at
their word but you have to imagine that
because she's a stone-cold killer now
she might have a little bit of fun with
Daenerys like oh wow you look kind of
dangerous for being so small what'll
happen is is if we get closer to the
Year they'll be dropping more teasers
for Season eight so of course I'll do
videos for that stuff when it drops but
I'll also do some cool history videos
when they drop the book in November for
stuff that's relevant to what's
happening in present-day or if they're
any special requests he with Rose
History videos always really fun to do
particularly when they reference stuff
or are similar to events that are
happening in present-day
leave all your requests for Game of
Thrones videos in the comments below
congratulations Julia Brooks you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to learn all about the early season
8 release date and click here to watch
george RR martin talk about the prequels
the main series finale and winds of
winter thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight